the good doctor is being recommended
more than Grey's Anatomy by you guys in
my comment section and in fact this
episode has popped up more times than
any other so let's get started I think
you may need a new mentor I'm dying
Oh dad took a turn I know I only watched
the first two episodes with you guys and
now I'm on the 18th and it feels like
I'm skipping around like crazy but this
was voted the number one episode by
episode ninja so I feel like I had to
check it out don't judge me
I'm excited 12 to 18 months and then
appreciate it if you didn't tell anyone
I want to know the diagnosis well in my
own time okay have you had a full workup
yes of course it could be a secondary
tumor metastasized to your brain from
somewhere else it could be a primary
tumor which means that it originated in
the brain or it could be a secondary
tumor let's say a lung tumor that
started in the lungs through the
lymphatic system where the blood went
into the brain and then created a
secondary tumor you should get a second
opinion showing up in a neurosurgeon for
30 years I think that qualifies as a
second opinion you know what's
interesting about being a doctor who's
practiced 30-something years as a
neurosurgeon you actually make really
bad decisions when it comes to your own
health it's notorious that doctors are
really bad patients and I totally agree
with this I'm the worst and in fact if I
have a patient that I'm treating and I
know as a doctor I know I'm gonna have
to take extra time I know I'm gonna have
to do a little arguing with them in
order to get them to take care of
themselves properly well given the
degree of the rotation and the fact that
the break is almost compound I say we're
dealing with a bimalleolar trimalleolar
fracture thank it what else
color blood flow is restricted is for
spying no so they're talking about this
ankle fracture when they say it's a
compound fracture means it's fractured
in multiple places when there's lack of
blood flow that means there's pressure
being put on the arteries or veins in
that area which is very dangerous cuz
that's called vascular compromise
meaning not enough blood is going to
that area in that area is in a crossing
or dying I'm gonna have to reset it now
almost like when they say resetting it's
exactly what you think it is just gonna
take a second I need you to count to
three
one one two I think that was kind of
accurate I don't know even my scream
match
shouldn't I be asleep for this well your
blood alcohol level complicates
anesthesia and we think you have a
concussion so we want to keep you
responsive we didn't give you a regional
nerve block so you shouldn't feel
anything this is actually similar to
what we do when we do a c-section the
mother is not asleep we do a regional
block just like this we need the mother
conscious in case we need to make
decisions so that she can help
facilitate the process if anything
happens I had a friend a neurosurgeon at
SF Muni she looked at the scan she came
to the same diagnosis Sean I have been
in Opera bulk glioma glioma is a type of
tumor when we say a tumor is inoperable
usually that's because the area where
it's found how encompassing is it you
know if a tumors spread throughout the
entire brain how are you gonna operate
you can't take out the entire brain
sometimes if we're very luckily and it's
localized to a specific region we can
just take that part out
but even then we're at risk at harming
the surrounding structures of the brain
and leaving someone with neurological
deficits you can imagine how awful that
could be like yeah okay take out my
tumor help me live but then I can no
longer speak horrible horrible
situations be reasonable thank you
Father
reasonable I have no idea what you're
talking more it'll be clear what the
hell up indicated I don't know twisted
his ankle either you lied to me before
you're blinding me now you spoil look
out hey hey be reasonable
his friends huh he's scared and you're
freaking him out good cop bad cop
the reason good cop bad cop works so
well is exactly based on the principle
that I've told you before in some of my
Wednesday check up videos so if you want
someone to see your point of view you
want to influence someone in a positive
way it's not ideal to put a stone in
between you it's not ideal to just state
your argument and be confrontational
about it because that person won't want
to change their beliefs but now on the
other hand if you can get that person to
see that you're on their side that you
have the same intentions
you're also a human and they can be see
eye to eye with you you're more likely
to convince them of something and good
cop backup is a fast track to achieving
that goal we're pledging and there's
there's a wheel of torture thing you got
to do for initiation torture but it's
more it's mostly stupid stuff that it's
like they drink a cup of olive oil or
either tablespoon of this and jump off
for no more educated in the land or
laundry you have to do laundry you know
like Yeti eat those laundry things oh my
god type as we easily could in 30
seconds guitars and eat detergent how
many do you have I don't know like six
maybe I feel like I shouldn't be here
even on a medical Channel explain to you
why that's bad I mean it's like don't
eat knives don't eat Forks and don't eat
Tide Pods the only time that I'll say
that someone may accidentally ingest at
iPod is like if you have a child very
young who's not aware and they see a
colorful pod and they think it's candy
and they swallow it but if you're an
adult or an adolescent and you're eating
Tide Pods come on you can do better I
know you can't
it's my schpeel a trauma is that he's
asking for you know our number two we
got an emergency thoracotomy we can give
you the remaining steps for closing cut
anchoring sutures clear labs to
reposition the bowel remove clamps from
the doís the resection aside keeping
clear of the underlying aorta when he
says clearing laps what he's talking
about
are those pads that we use to control
the bleeding or to put pressure or to
clean the site so that we can actually
see what we're doing when a patient has
some blood in place the nurse is
they're with us the assistants that are
there with us are counting each one of
those laps because if we leave one of
those in horrible situation it'll fester
bacterial infection all this stuff so
yes we count every tool we make sure
everything is in everything is out we
even have like a little wall of pockets
almost like a shoe organizer where we
put each one of the things that we count
them out afterwards while you run the
bowel for me
[Music]
when we say run the bowel what we're
doing is we're looking for any injuries
to the bowel
most commonly this happens in a gunshot
wound if it get if someone gets shot in
the abdomen right away the first step in
the trauma situation is to open the
patient do an explorative laparotomy
which means that you cut the stomach
open you run the bowel you see if
there's any injury anywhere because if
there's a lot of blood pooling in the
abdomen the patient could die very
quickly and you have to run the bowel
quickly but effectively to make sure
that you find the area that's bleeding
[Music]
Shawn is everything alright what
happened this time it's gonna bleed
somewhere when a capsule endoscopy to
check the entire length of the balfour
bleeding in leaks and give me a complete
coagulation metabolic profile a capsule
endoscopy is when you take a pill that
actually has a camera in it and it takes
about 24 hours to go through the system
and you get quality photos it
consistently photos and video it records
its way through the GI system which
allows you to see if there's any
bleeding anywhere in my past experience
what I've seen is that if someone is
bleeding and we suspect it's from an
upper GI source meaning from the stomach
the Safa guess what we do is we do an
endoscopy where you put the camera in
the mouth and you try and find where
that bleed is coming from and you can
control that bleed in a number of ways
if you think it's from the lower GI
bleed you could do a colonoscopy which
is just another form of endoscopy where
you put a camera up the button not sure
if they're doing a capsule endoscopy
here just to look cool for TV or because
they don't feel comfortable taking him
for an endoscopy because he's in a
critical state
now he's getting lab work that is
legitimate because when you take
detergent it can mess up the acid-base
balance in your blood it could mess with
the electrolytes of your blood and if it
messes with them too much it can kill
you our patient has disseminated
intravascular coagulation can anyone
tell me why that is very bad blood clots
form throughout the blood vessels and
rapidly deplete the body's clotting
factors thereby causing a systemic bleed
it's also a catch-22
if we treat the clotting he might end up
with a terminal bleed so di C is
actually a very rare condition it's
life-threatening the last time I saw it
was probably my residency when I was at
the intensive care unit and it's a
condition where you have excessive
clotting going on within the blood
vessels so it's intravascular and when
that happens you can have organs die
think stroke pulmonary embolism in the
lungs just think of it simply put as a
clotting condition where your body's
clotting a lot and because it's clotting
a lot it's using up all of its clotting
factors and platelets which then makes
you more susceptible to bleed you could
have a cross injury from his ankle or
bacterial infection he picked up before
during surgery it might have been sawed
off by drug use or we did this to him
and by we I mean Shawn he spaced out on
the Oh our when he was closing kind of
like he is now I'm listening
comforting he wasn't focused he got some
bad news about what it's a personal
matter
Shawn was distracted my personal issue
what did Lea come back she have a new
boyfriend is capable get cut off I have
an inoperable glioma 18 months there was
some surprises on your images the
previous diagnosis was incorrect you
have a glioblastoma multiforme worries
it in your palms oh I'm sure I don't
need to tell you this but it's the most
aggressive form of brain cancer ah
we estimate three maybe four months
someone's in trouble
do you need me to listen to you anymore
hope is irrelevant for me hope is
painful I don't want to spend what's
left of my life chasing my tail around
in a circle see I disagree with him a
little bit on the Hope aspect I
understand what he's feeling and it's
it's part of the process but hope is
really important in the medical
community hope is very important when
you have a disease because when you have
hope you could have a more positive
mental state and a more positive mental
state will give you the best chances
irrespective of what illness you have if
you have a cold
you'll feel better sooner if your mental
state is better if you have pain you'll
feel less of it if your mental state is
better so I think maintaining hope is
one of those ways nature allows us to
have a natural relief of whatever
suffering we're going through so I like
to hold out hope your tumor is located
at the base of your skull and open
cranial biopsy would tell us what's
wrong but there are blood vessels in the
way the biopsy would cause an aneurysm
or a bleed but if we go through your
nasal cribriform plate we can cross the
tentorium on the contralateral side and
avoid all those blood vessels
we can do a biopsy through your nose
Caden is still alive if we can keep it
that way there won't be an M&M review
which means no one will be asking
questions and no one will have to give
answers M&M is morbidity and mortality
conference that happens if someone gets
really sick or dies we take some of the
most complex cases during these meetings
and you have all the residents there all
the doctors that participated in the
case some specialists that are required
to attend this and basically we dissect
the case from the beginning to end
trying to figure out what we can do
better learn from our mistakes use it as
a learning opportunity and I've seen
these be incredibly educational but I've
also seen them backfire see doctors get
into near fistfights is that from an IV
you did the biopsy I did
we have a low-grade glioma how did GBM I
told you cancer Sean it's still cancer I
have to undergo brain surgery which is
really scary because I'm not the one
performing it five days a week for six
weeks of radiation
ten more weeks of chemotherapy and then
[Music]
and then with a little luck you and I
can go to the Super Bowl next season
yeah I almost became a concierge doctor
if you want to know what that is
check out my medical drama review of
Royal Pains click here click click stay
happy and healthy
[Music]